A square neck line is an attractive
addition to a pullover sweater.
Finishing a square neck line on
the machine can be a challenge.
Are you up for a challenge?
Well, let's get started.
This tutorial is one of our originals
from way back in 2010 here's a requested
update.
Please forgive the mashup of older
video, different lighting and voice.
We're creating a neat finish for a
square neck line using the Knit it Now.
Practice square neck line
pattern, knit a small swatch.
Basically you want to end up with
a shape that looks like this.
Now, if this were a round neck to knit a
basic band, I'd hang the neck edge back on
the machine with the wrong side facing.
I'd knit maybe six rows, knit, turning row
and knit six more rows to finish the band.
But wait, I don't want around neck.
When you fold back the turning row to
complete the band, the problem's really
clear.
There's a bunch of extra fabric where the
corner should be for the square neckline.
Now there'd be no problem
if this were hand knitting.
We'd simply place markers at the corners,
and as we knit the band, we'd knit three
together to make a neat, miter decrease
or double decrease at the corner, but knit
three together on the
machine isn't as easy.
Follow along as we work center double
decreases to create the public side of our
square band.
A mitered band is a beautiful
finish to a square neck line.
You'll work double decreases on the public
side of the band manually moving the
stitches and working short rows on
the facing side for a nice finish.
I've started with the sample
neck line casting on 70 stitches.
Knit for 30 rows, bind
off or remove the center.
30 stitches on waste yarn.
Knit 30 more rows on each side,
binding off each shoulder.
Block your swatch to make
it easier to work with.
The upper image used waste yard
to hold the center front stitches.
You can see that it gives a much smoother
finish than the lower image, which was
bound off before starting the band.
Start the band by hanging the garment
with the private or the wrong side facing.
After you hang the last
of the center stitches.
Use a pencil to Mark the next
needle on the needle bed.
This will be the start of the miter.
Do this on both sides.
Now finish hanging the side neck stitches
being careful to pick up the whole stitch.
Hang both sides.
Then at garment tension knit
one row to start the miter.
Start on the left side of the bed,
transfer each stitch right and left to the
Mark needle.
The Mark needle will have three stitches,
transfer all three stitches to the right
or towards the center of the bed.
You'll have two empty needles.
Transfer each of the side neck
stitches, two needles to the right.
Filling the empty needles.
Use whatever tool is comfortable for you.
A multi- stitch transfer tool
or a Garter bar is handy here.
Repeat the shaping for the other side.
Transfer one stitch right and
left to the marked needle.
Transfer all three stitches to the left.
Fill the empty needles with the remaining
side neck stitches, using the tool of your
choice.
When you finish the transfers on both
sides, knit one row, you will have
decreased a total of four stitches.
Repeat the double decreased
process six times.
You'll notice that I've marked my miter
stitch on the needle bed each time.
You'll be able to feel the Ridge of the
miter, but marking the bed comes in handy
and will be used later.
Your piece will look like this after
you've transferred and knit six times.
Create a turning row by knitting one row,
at a loser tension or turn the work with
the garter bar and add a garter Ridge.
You're now ready to knit the band facing.
If you knit straight up from here, you'll
have a total of 24 fewer stitches than
when you originally picked up the band.
You can fudge and just stitch the facing
down, but doing a few short rows on the
facing will give you squared corners
to completely encase the band.
In the next video, we'll knit
the second side of our band.
Let's think of it as a facing.
We will work some short row increases
to create the corners in that facing.